So what are Camel humps filled with?
It turns out, fat.
These fat humps can weigh as much as 80 pounds
and allow the Camel to comfortably go one
to two weeks without eating, if necessary.
Now, some of you out there might be saying
to yourselves, “Well, but 1 gram of fat
actually gets converted to more than 1 gram
of water during the metabolic process, so
it actually is a kind of water store.”
This is correct in principle, but ends up
not helping the Camel out any in terms of
water supply.
Even though more water is produced processing
the fat than there was fat, gram for gram,
the metabolic process actually uses quite
a bit of water due to the arid conditions
Camels live in.
Basically, they lose a lot of water through
their lungs getting the oxygen necessary to
process the fat.
So the net effect of processing the fat actually
results in less water than there was before.
So where do the Camels store extra water?
It turns out, mostly in their blood and other
places there are already fluids in their body.
There really is no central water store anywhere
in a Camel.
What allows a Camel to survive in desert environments
is mainly just that they are incredibly efficient
with their water usage.
In fact, they are so efficient, that in milder
climates a Camel can get all the water they
need just from eating relatively green plant
life.
Their bodies conserve water in just about
every way imaginable.
For instance, when they pee, their urine contains
very little water, being more of a pasty substance
that has approximately the consistency of
syrup.
On the other end of things, their feces comes
out almost completely dried out and can be
used right away by humans for making fires
or the like.
For comparison, human fecal matter typically
is made up of about 75% water.
A major area most animals lose water, particularly
in arid environments, is by breathing.
Camels are no exception, but their breathing
system is much more efficient than most.
Their nostrils have a mechanism for trapping
moisture in their breath before it is exhaled.
This moisture is then returned to their bodily
fluids.
The other major area most mammals lose water
in hot areas is through sweat.
It turns out, Camels don’t need to sweat
very much to stay cool.
There are a few things that go into this,
most impressive of which is that their body
temperatures can comfortably range from about
93 degrees Fahrenheit to 106 degrees Fahrenheit
without any real negative side effects.
Their bodies are also well equipped for keeping
heat out (for more on this see the Bonus Factoids
section below).
After a cool desert night, their body temperature
will be around 93 degree Fahrenheit.
Given their large size and their body’s
ability to keep heat out, it ends up taking
a while for their temperature to rise to closer
to the 106 degree Fahrenheit level.
So in some cases, the Camel may not need to
sweat at all during a given day, depending
on the ambient temperature and how hard they
are working.
However, if they do get close to that 106
degree Fahrenheit threshold, their sweat mechanism
will kick in.
Like the rest of their body when it comes
to water usage, their sweat mechanism is as
efficient as sweating can be, with the sweat
evaporating at the skin surface level rather
than soaking into their hair and wasting some
of the cooling effect in evaporating off that
hair.
Another interesting thing is how a Camel’s
body actually manages water internally.
When they need water, their body will first
get the water from all fluid parts of their
body except the bloodstream.
This allows their blood to continue to flow
normally, even when they are relatively dehydrated.
They can withstand up to a 25% weight decrease
from water loss and it isn’t until they
start getting close to that level that their
main store of water in their blood starts
to get used.
For comparison on how impressive that 25%
number is, most mammals will experience cardiac
failure around 12-15% weight decrease due
to water loss.
This all adds up to a Camel that isn’t carrying
any extra weight being able to go around two
to three weeks in a desert environment without
needing to drink water.
On the other hand, if the Camel is being used
as a pack Camel and is carrying a lot of weight,
they can go three or four days in that environment
without needing to take in any water.
A Camel’s blood cells also have some unique
properties among mammals.
The blood cells are in the shape of elongated
ovals, instead of round, which allows them
to flow more freely when the Camel is dehydrated.
The blood cells are also able to handle large
swings in water levels without rupturing,
which is essential for the blood stream’s
ability to store extra water.
Camels have three eyelids.
Two of the eyelids have eye lashes which help
protect their eyes from sand.
The third is a very thin lid which works as
a sort of “windshield wiper” to clean
off their eyes.
It closes/opens from side to side rather than
up and down.
It is also thin enough that the Camels can
see through it somewhat.
So in a sandstorm or otherwise windy day where
sand is being stirred up, they can close that
lid to protect their eyes from the sand, but
still see where they are going.